when you come here with an agenda as you
came with an agenda the girl in the
corner you want to say you've seen me
before you've seen me on social media so
you're whatever you've seen of me in the
clips you've come with that Vim but you
haven't seen the full clip you haven't
seen watch the full episodes you have to
understand sure match that energy you
matched how you perceived you came in
your Vibe was very aggressive you was
very is it is it ever question is it
possible that you just took it the wrong
way no of course I mean I agree because
this is it is it possible as women
sometimes we take things the wrong way
it's not even a woman